alle na ja fast alle fanden die idee
toll auch die kleine pia und ihre mutter
der regenbogen sollte zeichen der
hoffnung sein ein zeichen der korona
krise so malte pira ein buntes bild
hängte es ans fenster ihrer wohnung die
halbe klasse tat das doch dann kam eine
nachricht des staatlichen schulamtes der
regenbogen sei ein zeichen der
homosexuellenbewegung das eher schädlich
für das kindliche gemüt also weg damit
mutter basak war schockiert da kommt
eine aufmunterung von einem kind sie
sollen uns zum lächeln bringen uns
glücklich machen und dann so etwas
das ist sexistisch was geht in deren
köpfen vor
diese leute treffen entscheidungen im
bildungsbereich
das tut mir leid für mein land und für
unsere kinder für den journalisten
bülent mai ist dieser vorfall nur ein
beispiel von vielen das zeigt dass sich
etwas ändert an der stimmung im land die
türkei unter staatspräsident erdogan
werde immer religiöser nationalistischer
und autoritärer der anders ist und
anders denkt wird als terrorist
abgestimmt wird
es wird nicht geduldet dass sich ein
anderes politisches machtzentrum
entwickelt wir werden von einer führung
regiert die keine andere meinung zulässt
selbst wenn jemand eine andere flagge
aufhängt wird das nicht toleriert er
meint diesen vorfall geschehen am 19
es ist der nationalfeiertag zum gedenken
an den beginn des türkischen
unabhängigkeitskrieges 1919 türkische
flaggen wehen auf den balkonen in
kayseri hängt ein junger iraner sein
handtuch zum trocknen auf mit dem emblem
des kritischen juni in jack einige
fühlen sich provoziert die polizei nimmt
den mann fest unter dem jubel der
türkischen nachbarn verletzter
nationalstolz heiligt die mittel
vor gut einem monat hat ein 85 jähriger
mann in den sozialen medien einen
kritischen post gelegt
während der ausgangssperre wurde er von
zu hause abgeholt in polizeigewahrsam
gebracht und verhört aber hasserfüllte
aussagen von denen die die regierung
unterstützen werden in keiner weise
bestraft so trat dem konservativen
sender
die glühende anhängerin selbst erneuern
auf und drohte
unsere familie kann 50 leute erledigen
wir sind dafür gut ausgerüstet was
material und entschlossenheit angeht die
sollten aufpassen bei uns in der
wohngegend habe ich drei bis fünf leute
auf der liste
wir stehen zu unserem führer und werden
nicht erlauben dass ihr fertig machen
leute wie neujahr haben nichts zu
befürchten
dem provinz blatt es coach eli aber
wurde schon eine kleine corona meldung
zum verhängnis die journalisten hatten
fakten präsentiert die aber waren
offenbar unerwünscht und hatte die
nachricht erreicht dass in einer
pandemie klinik zwei leute an coop 19
gestorben waren
wir haben das gegenprojekt ich habe die
meldung gelesen bevor visier ausgegeben
haben und bin dann nach hause
ich bin schon etwas älter und gehe früh
schlafen um mitternacht klopft es an
unsere tür und meine frau sagt die
polizei ist hier und will dass du mit
kommst in meinem ganzen berufsleben in
40 jahren ist mir so was noch nie
passiert die haben gesagt ich solle mich
anziehen
sie müssten mich mitnehmen als ich das
foto gesehen habe war ich geschockt
ich konnte nicht glauben an journalisten
den ich seit jahren kenne
in einer solchen lage zu sehen ich habe
sofort alle möglichen leute angerufen
habe den vorfall in den sozialen medien
veröffentlicht und gegen seine
verhaftung protestiert immer farrow
gallery ist abgeordneter der
prokurdischen partei kdp und jemand der
sich wehrt dass das regime keine kritik
duldet hat er schon oft am eigenen leib
vorbereitung für ein interview mit dem
opposition sender arte tv der sendet aus
köln aus sicherer entfernung
thema sind auch die 45 gewählten
bürgermeister der hdp die wegen
angeblicher nähe zur terror organisation
pkk abgesetzt wurden
als gaga jo lang mit geld und mikrofon
dagegen protestieren wollte gegen die
staatsgewalt dazwischen
wir wurden von der polizei
zurückgedrängt
in dem gerangel haben dann zwei
polizeibeamte nach und getreten
ihr vorgesetzter hat mich regelrecht aus
der menge heraus gezogen um mich vor
weiteren physischen angriffen zu
schützen
ich habe darauf hingewiesen dass man
mich daran hindert öffentlich zu
sprechen dass es sich um einen versuch
handelt die stimme eines abgeordneten zu
unterdrücken
oppositionsabgeordnete haben es immer
schwerer sich gehör zu verschaffen
ein beispiel ist der streit um die
entlastung von zehntausenden
strafgefangenen mitte april war
hoffnungslos überfüllte gefängniszellen
bot städten für das corona virus wurden
hatte die regierungskoalition ein
umstrittenes amnestiegesetz
durchgedrückt
[Musik]
die ausgangs erlaubnis von 60.000
gefangenen würde ende mai auslaufen
wir haben erlaubt dass sie wegen der
epidemie die gefängnisse verlassen
wir werden diese erlaubnis nun um zwei
weitere monate verlängern
tumulte im parlament hatte es gegeben
als das amnestiegesetz mit regierungs
mehrheit verabschiedet wurde
straftäter so die kritik kämen raus
politische gefangene aber blieben inter
gittern wie der ehemalige vorsitzende
der pro kurdischen hdp selahattin
demirtas wie der kunstmäzen osman kavala
oder wie der publizist ahmet altan sie
alle sitzen weiter in haft alle wegen
des vorwurfs der terror unterstützung
journalisten und menschenrechtler wurden
von dem entlastungsgesetz ausgenommen
obwohl sie eigentlich überhaupt nicht in
haft sitzen sollten sie haben nun ein
höheres co mit 19 infektionsrisiko und
das ist sehr enttäuschend
der mafia boss dagegen kam raus martin
jaquet links im bild hatte im knast
besuch bekommen von erdogans
koalitionspartner für devlet bahceli
chef der nationalistischen mhp ist der
schwerverbrecher ein verdienter
staatsbürger dem gnade gebühre
und so geschah es auch tatsächlich ist
herr bachelor der geistigen urvater
dieses gesetz er kam mittags extra zur
abstimmung ins parlament seine partei
votierte für die vorlage er zeigte in
deutlicher weise dass sie das gesetz nur
seinem eigenen politischen vorteil dient
das kind an ricoh ist ein kurdischer
rechtsanwalt aus die arag und sitzt für
die größte oppositionspartei chp im
parlament an ricoh kämpft für die
menschenrechte in seinem land und legt
sich immer wieder mit der aktei des
präsidenten an
sie haben mich auf eine liste gesetzt
mit namen von leuten die von den radio
und fernsehsendern nicht mehr für
interviews eingeladen werden sollen sagt
er
so sendet er nun ein eigenes programm im
internet
präsident erdogan habe nach und nach ein
zentralistisches autoritäres system
erschaffen sagt handelt die akp hat
gemerkt dass es nicht ausreichend wird
lediglich die htp zu kriminalisieren
denn die hat sehr viele mitglieder und
eine große anhängerschaft
als sie merkten dass sie die hdt nicht
schwächen können greifen sie nun uns an
sie wollen uns mundtot machen sie
versuchen uns als vaterlandsverräter als
terroristen und als kriminelle
hinzustellen als eine partei die für die
zukunft der türkei nichts gutes bringen
wird der präsident beschuldigt die
opposition den nationalen kampf gegen
das corona virus zu sabotieren sein zorn
gilt dabei immer wieder der chp in
dieser zeit in der wir doch eigentlich
im land und in unserer nation mehr
einheit zusammengehörigkeit
brüderlichkeit solidarität und moral
bräuchten in dieser zeit führt die chp
korruption und sie schafft unheil
dieser auftritt der chp vorsitzenden von
istanbul jana kaftan joop war anlass
eines rachefeldzugs anderhalb tv hatte
sie verkündet die zeit erdogan sei bald
abgelaufen die medienaufsicht wertete
das als aufruf zum putsch und bestrafte
den sender
während reisen darf nun fünf wochen lang
nicht moderieren hulk tv muss strafe
zahlen
sie hat das wort putsch nicht einmal in
den mund genommen
das einzige was sie gesagt hat war dass
diese regierung den zenit überschritten
hat und weg muss ob durch vorgezogene
wahlen oder auf andere art entscheidend
sei dass diese regierung nicht mehr so
weitermachen könne
diese worte wurden von der
medienaufsicht als putsch aufruf
interpretiert und wir wissen alle dass
sie solche entscheidungen nicht alleine
treffen
ich bin erst seit sechs wochen im amt
mein chefredakteur dr
seitdem kümmere ich mich nur um
strafbescheide über 26.000 euro soll
halb tv insgesamt zahlen für den kleinen
sender eine menge geld
unser budget ist nicht sehr groß die
strafen die gegen uns verhängt wurden
haben uns sehr hart getroffen
denn sie schränken unsere werbeeinnahmen
ein und können bis hin zum sendungs
ausfall gehen dazu kommen noch die
geldstrafen
wir werden also doppelt getroffen und
die auswirkungen dieser maßnahmen sind
für uns in die bevölkerung möchte einen
sender der ihnen korrekte informationen
gibt es ist als wenn man den leuten die
luft zum atmen nimmt dann sehnen sie
sich nach einem sender wie dem uns oder
strafen gab es auch für eine andere
talksendung von halb tv in der die
korona politik der regierung erdogan
kritisiert wurde
neben einer geldstrafe musste halt tv
statt der talksendung eine dokumentation
über traditionelle handarbeiten senden
unten im bild der lauftext wegen eines
verstoßes gegen türkisches gesetz wurde
unser programm gestoppt und stattdessen
dieser beitrag veröffentlicht sie
versuchen uns zu schikanieren uns ganz
zu schließen dass wagen sie nicht sagt
shirin weisen sie und die anderen bei
halb tv wollen weitermachen solange es
gibt gegen viele meiner kollegen wurden
prozesse angestrengt und sie haben ihre
jobs verloren
die unabhängigen medien in der türkei
machen gerade noch fünf prozent aus
ihnen gegenüber steht eine medienmacht
von regierungsfreundlichen konzernen
sie befinden sich in der hand des
präsidentenpalastes und obwohl der
palast 95 prozent der medien
kontrolliert haben sie immer noch angst
vor unseren fünf prozent
das türkische strafrecht wird immer
wieder als keule gegen kritiker
eingesetzt so auch nach den jüngsten
homophoben bemerkungen des chefs der
obersten religionsbehörde diyanet ali
erbas der hatte ehebruch und
homosexualität als ursachen für
viruskrankheiten wie aids bezeichnet vor
denen es die menschen zu schützen gelte
bald werde aber schweizer
hexenverbrennung aufrufen kritisierte
die anwaltskammer von ankara
sofort sprang der präsident seinem
obersten islam beauftragten zur seite
dieses thema liegt nicht in der
zuständigkeit der anwaltskammer von
ankara jeder sollte seinen platz kennen
jeder sollte seine grenzen kennen der
stil der kritik an den ansichten des
chefs der religionsbehörde ging gegen
dessen persönlichkeit
es war ein direkter und vorsätzliche
angriffe auf den islam und ein angriff
auf unseren chef der religionsbehörde
ist ein angriff auf den start
nun ermittelt die staatsanwaltschaft
gegen die anwaltskammer ein neues gesetz
soll die kammer auf linie bringen
der präsident und seine partei kämpfen
um den machterhalt
wer sie kritisiert wird verfolgt als
staatsfeind verleumdet wer nicht für ihn
ist ist gegen ihn und damit gegen die
türkische nation der alleinherrscher
recep tayyip erdogan
so attestierte es kürzlich die
bertelsmann stiftung habe aus der türkei
längst eine autokratie gemacht man kann
sagen dass wir in der türkei
mittlerweile das stadium einer de facto
diktatur erreicht haben bei der
präsident das ergebnis von wahlen nicht
mehr akzeptiert er erlaubt der
opposition nicht den mund aufzumachen
dutzende von oppositionsanhängern hält
er im gefängnis ein solches land kann
man nicht mehr als demokratie bezeichnen
es ist ein land in dem die regierenden
selbst bunte regenbogen bilder verbieten
wollen
die mutter der kleinen reihe versteht
nicht wovor die schulbehörde eigentlich
angst hat wir haben tolle reaktionen auf
die bilder bekommen denn alle brauchen
in diesen zeiten etwas positives und
wenn unsere kinder so etwas machen dann
zaubert uns dass ein lächeln ins gesicht
alle die piraeus bild sahen hätten sich
gefreut sagt nowak
der streit um den regenbogen aber
bedeutet nichts gutes für die zukunft
ihres landes
[Musik]